hey guys today is the 20th of April my
name is just and here's some gaming
related news to get you all caught up
the latest game informer show revealed
that Sony has thought about the
possibility of a PlayStation 5 oddworld
creator Lorne Lanning said he previously
asked Shuhei Yoshida what the
PlayStation 5 he may look like so much
he replied you mean if implying that
there may never be a PlayStation 5
running out of these shita didn't give
him a clear answer as to whether the PS
4.5 / neo is in the works but Yoshida
did say we need to be more agile none of
us know what the future really looks
like so how do we adapt to it faster in
the past gaming console life cycles have
lasted around five to seven years and
both Sony and Microsoft have suggested
they're exploring ways to adapt pasta
that said xboxes Phil Spencer said there
will be no xbox one and a half full out
full of most recent patch has officially
landed on the pc and here's what's near
the update has added support for Mays
$25 fair harbor DLC pack as well as
survival mode a beta for the update is
available right now on steam and the
final version will be coming to PC as
well as ps4 and xbox one in the coming
weeks survival mode adds a lot of
restrictions to make the game more
challenging and realistic as realistic
as the post-apocalypse guess anyway
today's patch also fixes a number of
bugs and brings along a bunch of general
stability and performance improvements
you can check out the full patch notes
as well as instructions on how to opt
into the steam beta in our story on
gamespot sony is adding two factor
authentication to PlayStation Network to
improve account security sony confirmed
that they plan to launch the feature at
a later date after a user discovered
that the latest ps3 update made mention
of two-factor verification as it does on
other platforms the feature would
require users
submit two forms of account verification
before they're granted access to their
account sony told gamespot in order to
further safeguard our users and their
accounts ever bearings offer a two-step
verification feature this feature has
been available for xbox live users since
2013 and is also used on other online
gaming services such as Battlement and
stains let me know down in that comment
section if you reckon there's going to
be a PlayStation 5 and be sure to head
to GameSpot's where we've got news on a
new division exploit and rocket leagues
you know that's everything I have for
you today we shall leave me your
thoughts in their comment section and I
will catch you again tomorrow